[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
or baum depends on how you want to say
it if you're my dad listening you
probably won't like if i say
bomb that's your name
it's baum you're rosenbaum oh man you're
facts dude
vexed uh ryan's vaxxed which means we
could be in here safely and you know
after this uh
maybe we'll end this whole thing this
episode on the outro with the hug
yeah i mean we gotta wait i'm still in
my two week you're not
two weeks yet no so i can't hug you
after the 20th
all right so stay tuned because on the
20th uh
he's gonna get hugged uh-huh hard yeah
if you had a good week good weekend
yeah i mean i'm sorry stressed are you
i mean always but you know it's nice to
be double vaxxed and
uh we're the stressful part is figuring
out how to re-enter the world and now
that things are gonna happen again yeah
how do you slowly get
back into it how do you do it you know
can you give a you know an elbow bump
you know can you do a fist bump yeah can
we do it i went to the laker game
and you have to wear a mask they don't
let food or drink at your seat
so you had to have a drink before you
walked to your seats it was odd but
nonetheless it was it was fun it was
nice to be at a a basketball game
um thank you genie bus for the for the
tickets and uh
it was it was fun name drop a serious
name well i have to because we're
friends actually i'm friends with her so
it's like hey you know
let's go call it a name drop if you want
if my best friend was sylvester stallone
i'd say hey
oh shout out to my boy sylvester it's
only the only it's only the owner of the
entire damn team
she you wouldn't know it she's so damn
laid-back and cool and you know why we
became friends
because many moons ago i was at a party
a lakers party that i was invited to for
the wb or something
and this woman came up to me with her
friend and she was really nervous and
she was like hey uh you know i'm i
really like the show and i'm like oh my
god thank you and i was just like a dude
i was a regular guy and she was
just a girl and there was just few
people talking i did i had no
clue to who she is on my mother's life i
swear to you i had no idea because i'd
never been to a basketball game i didn't
know anything about the lakers really
and she goes here here's my card if you
ever want to come to lakers game and she
walked away
and i go it's a genie boss vice
president of the at the time she's vice
president now she's the president
and i got holy [ __ ] my friend roger's
like you should probably call her man
he talks like that he's like hey man you
should probably call her
so i emailed her and i said hey
you gave me your card i don't know
whatever she goes how many tickets you
need
i have four friends valet
treated me like a damn king got there
sat behind them
actually uh and we had so much fun
and she just was like you're just so
cool and such a regular guy and
uh you know you didn't know who i was
and i really liked that you were just so
nice anyway
and you're invited to whenever you want
to come to a game you're invited
and so now it's been 15
20 years whatever it is i go to any game
i want now
it's it's a luxury it's an amazing it's
one of those things
it's just a lucky thing that happened in
my life very grateful but
i remember it was game seven i go i'm in
town good luck tomorrow night she goes
you're coming right
and i go to game seven of the nba finals
against the
celtics she goes yeah i got you you have
four tickets whatever you want
she's amazing she's just an amazing
human being and she's always been so
nice to my friends and uh so thank you
so name drop the drop drop drop chop
chop
uh thank you for listening to the
podcast everybody if you want to
subscribe just go to youtube
and type in inside of you with michael
rosenbaum and then subscribe
we also have great clips if you want to
watch clips from other episodes or
full episodes i prefer you watch the
whole episode um
and subscribe please do and you can also
subscribe on spotify stitcher apple
and please write a review please
subscribe if you're here for the lovely
charisma carpenter
and you dig the podcast it means a huge
amount i've been doing this podcast for
a while i'm not one of these people who
just jumped in the bandwagon and
during the pandemic and god bless him
but uh i'd really appreciate the
subscription you know what i mean also
the socials ryan give them the social
media handles
yeah inside of you pod on twitter at
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook
there you go and uh the band sunspin my
band sunspin just go to sunspin.com
and we're playing may 29th saturday may
29th
two shows you can get tickets uh go to
sunspin.com you could also book us for
zooms and book the band there's tons of
merch
if you want any inside of you um
swag swag go to the online inside of you
online store you can get
even smallville lunchbox or some lex
luthor autographs
inside of you hats shirts uh all that
stuff's there
also you can join the lovely patreon i
will i don't know what i would do
without my patrons
and if you don't know patreon is it's
pretty amazing ask anybody
if you want to subscribe and do a little
bit extra
for the podcast um you could join
there's different tiers you get merch
for me
you get to ask guests questions there's
bonus episodes
ryan and i are gonna do a bonus episode
today oh yay so just go to patreon.com
inside of you and join and i will write
you a message
as soon as i see that you're there i'll
see your message i'll see that you
became a patron
and i will message you back um today's
episode is
is a is a good one um charisma carpenter
she uh she's lovely she opens up she had
some
thoughts about me before she got to know
me and uh you know well we we talked
about that
uh we talked about her divorce uh she
was very open
and a little bit about joss whedon um
uh her 13 year old son who she loves
dearly but
i guess could be a dick what are you
doing mom
and i'm like why don't you look at him
and say what are you doing
i'm 13 year old 13 year olds are 13 year
olds can go at you
they can they're fearless what do you do
man i can't imagine with a 13 year old
girl
hey you better not what did you what
what i don't know man
that's one age i think about a lot that
i do not miss i do not miss being 13.
yeah i don't remember what it was like
to be 13. i'm sure i was a little dick
my parents were dicks too it's not a
good mix me being a dick and
their dicks as well a lot of dicks
flapping around a lot of big dicks
uh i love you guys i love you uh
listening to the podcast and staying
with us and sticking with us and all
that jazz
a lot of great stuff coming up a lot of
great guests coming up um
big shout out to ryan and bryce and um
it's not westwood one anymore
it's cumulus it's cumulus now all right
and uh they're running the show they're
uh they're uh they're helping us out and
giving us a lot of love so
anyway thanks why don't we just jump
into it let's get inside of charisma
carpenter
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you know what's amazing is uh you know
i've known you i mean when i say no i
mean it's not like we've been close
friends for a long time but we know of
each other for many many years
and we've always been very like hey and
we see each other at conventions and
it's fun
but like you you when you start to look
someone up and all their stuff and you
realize
i don't know this person at all not only
that's why i felt when we did my con
together i was like
you were telling all these amazing
stories and i just feel like i've been
missing out all this time
by not digging deeper into who you are
and getting to know you more making a
bigger offer i know but
what's amazing is is like you've had
such a great and cool career on cool
like cool shows like veronica mars and
charmed and
buffy and angel and like you've done
movies with stallone and you've done
like so much stuff and then i look at
like holy [ __ ] she's faced a lot of
adversity too i mean she's like went
through a divorce you
you know the whole uh toxic work
environment thing you've been through
and then
i read about the the thing that's been
public knowledge that you've probably
talked about at ad nauseam but the whole
uh former police officer who attacked
you and your friends on a beach who was
a serial raper who like
got sentenced to 50-something years in
prison and you kind of closed the case
with uh
it just i mean it's i didn't know any of
this [ __ ]
it's along it i know i packed a lot of
life in my 50 years
yeah do you feel like now that you've
faced all these things do you feel
sort of uh i don't know empowered in a
way
like you've i look like i've been
through it i know how to deal with this
i've been through the darkest of times i
can get out of any other dark times you
got
do you feel that way or do you still get
sort of are you still sensitive at all
that's a great question i'm not sure
that it's like you know it's funny you
ask that because i have a friend named
brett who survived cancer
and once he survived cancer he's just
like i don't sweat the small stuff
anymore
like nothing matters it is not a big
deal
you know like there are just no big
deals and for me i think it's the
opposite i feel like everything's a big
deal
i feel like everything is important i
feel
people deserve you know justice is
important i'm very big on justice
and doing the right thing and making the
world a little bit of a better place
so i feel it heightened my sense of
um responsibility to
my fellows and to be a good citizen
and to do the right thing and to use my
platforms in
those ways and to call out [ __ ] and
a call out
you know it's it's very difficult it's
got to be hard to be on the internet and
you know even like we always which oh
should i not say this
everybody's sensitive should i say this
is just going to hurt somebody's
feelings or
you know and to be brave enough to you
know do what you did recently which we
could talk about later if you want but
it's just like to use it as a platform
to express yourself
and help people is a much cooler thing
than to just
throw out stuff out there and go oh look
laugh at me like me
love me it's it's a very delicate
situation
in there too yeah well you do do that
you have a lot of funny stuff like i
just read
uh one of your tweets about jeff
goldblum another cool story how he
called you up
for what was it for uh right away for
hideaway
yeah it was a movie way back when right
and he called you up because he wanted
you to audition so
jeff goldblum calls you up did you did
you know he was going to call you did
someone say jefferson
i did so i used to belong to the
playhouse west on lancashire it's
um where robert carnegie was the acting
teacher that's where that was my
formal sort of
theater um valiance or where i learned
to act i guess
in he taught on samford meisner
technique
so i guess jeff goldblum was on the
board
of that theater and um i guess
robert had told jeff to come and audit
or he they had had some sort of
conversation that they were
jeff is going to do a movie and maybe he
mentioned that he wanted to
book somebody and so i think maybe
robert
had given him word to come and see me so
he came and audited a class that i was
in and then after class pulled me aside
and said
you know i'm i'm gonna be in this movie
and i'm looking for somebody to be my
daughter and i
i would really love to bring you in to
audition i can send you the script if
you're interested if you if you feel
like you're ready for that or whatever
nice that i am
and so he said great and so he sent me
the script
and then later called had his off you
know had his office send it and then
later called to say hey are you ready
is it do you have any questions do you
you know because i had never been in an
audition before
like that was literally michael that was
like that was the
audition that changed my life because i
had been an acting class
i had done the the stanford meisner
technique
i learned about like listening and how
important it is
and being in the moment and like all of
these things right so you're an acting
class and you're working on it and you
know
like you know when you're in a scene
with somebody when you're
just on fire right when it's just so
smooth and you don't feel like you're
acting you're you're actually
being in the scene so i go into this
audition
and i'm reading the scene with jeff
goldblum and i it's my first audition
ever in my life and he's playing my dad
and then at one point he just stood up
and stood over me because i'm like this
rebellious teen
and he stood over me like a dad would do
and he's also a very
large tall man yeah and he's so in the
moment and
when he stood up it was like
nobody else was in the room it was him
and i having a
full-on full-on argument about what i
will and will not do
and i'm not having it and it
i just i just was so in the moment
living
to moment listening hearing playing off
of him
and we were done and the scene was over
i
left that building it was over on warner
brothers it was actually
on the lot at warner brothers and i'm
walking between warehouses
and i say to myself this
is what i'm meant to do i don't care if
i get this part
that was the most amazing experience i
was doing exactly
what i've been training to do wow i can
do this this is my destiny
what if it was a shitty audition would
you felt the same way i don't care i
don't know
because that's not what happened that's
not what i see that's why my mind works
i always think okay you were great last
night but you're gonna suck tomorrow
that's unfortunately how my mind works
like you're never
gonna it's never enough it's never
freaking enough but that in that moment
you're young
you're ambitious you have this wonderful
encounter with goldblum this great
audition
and you felt like this is what i want to
do for the rest of my life 100
and you know i think where you're what
you're talking about is
is true i think two things i'm sorry
that that's how
where your brain goes to and i really
hope that changes soon i'm working on it
because you do deserve that and then
second of all i think
what is interesting about that is there
is a difference
between the way i was
back in the day when you're really young
and your whole life is in front of you
and you just feel like the stakes don't
matter you don't have a mortgage you
don't have a house you don't have a kid
you don't have college around the corner
like nothing's it it's like on to the
next i feel like to
hollywood like you have more auditions
like i would audition 900 times a week
so it's like who cares if i didn't get
that part i'll get the next one you know
it just but now when you get older the
auditions come fewer and far between
and the stakes are higher and you know
the the actual the actual projects are
better quality so you're meeting with
higher-end people
and prestigious projects and and these
people that you
really want to impress right so
yeah you know i totally have those
moments you just don't want to [ __ ] the
bed
you can avoid [ __ ] the bag
oh my god i mean do you get do you
do you have it now or did you have any
sort of anxiety before auditions then or
were you
it sounds like you were a free spirit
you were sort of just going forward
every week all these auditions but now
do you think things have changed or
you're like oh my gosh
everything's on this i got to be great
i'm getting anxiety yeah the anxiety
came
later it always does doesn't it why
after you've had some success you think
okay why is my anxiety still here it
should be gone because i've dealt with
all this stuff i'm used to it
but you never get used to it no i think
that's a great question asked my
therapist but i have an
inkling of an idea and i think it stakes
it's also if you feel safe on a set
or in in a scene with somebody like if
they're not a safe person
it's very hard for you if you don't have
chemistry or a genuine
um need to my dog wants to be on the lap
with me that's perfectly fine
this is cristiano ronaldo oh my gosh
cristiano
um hi very cute um
so i think there's how safe you feel
and then i also think um
i don't know i i just think it's a
myriad of different possibilities yeah i
think you know definitely
especially on set when you feel safe and
you see feel like everybody's got your
back when you feel like the other actor
is listening and he's there for you and
he wants
you to be your best there's something
really nice about that
and uh but we also have to
be able to push through when say like i
remember
reading a long time ago and this has
always stayed with me and
was in some like you know apocalyptic
type movie
where like a volcano is going off and
like it's a very integral
scene and they have to get it in one
shot and you're in a scene with harrison
ford
you know it was like some like massive
six days seven nights
six days seven nights or something maybe
it was and you know like
the pressure is on to get it in one take
yeah um you have to also be reliable
you know and professional enough to
overcome your anxiety
and you know i'm just basically trying
to avoid those situations
yeah you know what's crazy is like you
were we always have odd jobs like i
could tell you i worked at a grocery
store for years i could tell you that i
worked at a petland discounts uh
cleaning chinchilla [ __ ] at six a.m i
could tell you that i worked at a
go-cart track as a mechanic and a
roller rink dj and all these things but
like you know
you you've done some odd jobs i mean now
you waited tables but you worked
you worked i guess in real estate right
i was a i worked
i was a leasing agent at a at a place
but that was my least interesting job i
think my best job was i was an aerobics
instructor and i worked at a video store
and then i think uh do they still have
aerobics instructors can you call them
that do you ever hear
oh you guys want to take aerobics next
tuesday no actually they have that
position anymore it was at a family
fitness
back in the 90s uh or
late 80s it would have been and then um
and then what was that oh i i actually i
know i
i am a waitress but what makes it
interesting about when i was at waitress
was that it was at my parents restaurant
and my dad fired me
like you know you're bad when your dad
fired why did he fire you
because he admit i wasn't trustworthy
enough to work the dinner
um so i worked the lunch shift and i had
a table of eight people and a big ass
tray
with all the food that my um my dad was
in the kitchen at that
for the lunch hour i guess the chef had
called in or whatever and so he was
doing it
he loaded up the tray i picked up the
tray and they went through
the kitchen door which you know swings
and just as i was walking out the
swinging door
tipped the back of my tray because it
was that big and it was just enough
for me to just lose my my positioning
of the tray and everything went on the
floor crash and my dad looked up and he
goes you're fired
he said you're fired on the spot now did
he ever apologize this because
my father may have said a lot of things
and he may have
may have made me feel like crap and dumb
and all these things but
did he ever say i'm sorry harsh it was
it was it was it wasn't a it's not as
harsh as it sounded it was like
it was he was frustrated but it was
it needed to be done how i mean there
are three ways i could think of as an
actor that i would say fired and you're
saying it was pleasant so
he didn't obviously go you're fired he
said now let's see if i can make
if i could sell it sweetheart no there
was no sweetheart okay forget the
sweetheart
it was totally good okay go ahead let me
see if this works
okay you're fired
it's a really good reading thank you it
was somewhere between that
and like you know he looked down he
looked at me
he looked down and then it was just like
the inevitable
you know and he didn't say
inevitable charisma he didn't say
charisma we're gonna let you go he said
and of course this is what happens
we're done here you know like that did
you cry no
you're like it was great he was right i
was really to be honest with you i was
relieved
oh my god i can't possibly imagine being
you know i remember my dad trying to
teach me to drive a stick shift
and he's like no i told you to put your
foot i go that's it get the [ __ ] out of
the car
get out of the car he is giving me an
anxiety attack full-on
he raises his voice at everything
everything in the world
get your books off the counter why are
they there i'm like oh my god
chris farley take it easy just like
everything kitchen's closed
the kitchen was always closed after
dinner who does that to a child
oh my god i just said that to donovan
the other day
my son came came home at like midnight
and he wanted me to like make reheat him
some food he's like will you make it
very good no the kitchen's closed if you
wanted dinner you should have been here
for dinner time it's like midnight no
the kitchen's closed oh my god well
there you have it hey still making the
freaking food
what was your childhood did you have a
happy childhood were you were your
parents
pretty cool easy going besides firing
you on the spot
it doesn't it wasn't that hard i know um
i think it was like a mixed experience
my childhood it was a lot of you know it
was
you know fun a lot of surrounded by a
lot of family which is
you know in some some instances a good
thing and in other instances
like less so um but i do have happy
memories for sure
did they support your acting chaotic
you're acting on it they did
yeah they were excited to see their
daughter as an actress
so they did they take you to auditions
at a young age or are you old enough at
that point
no i was grown so i grew up
uh as a performer i grew up in vegas and
i always
dancing was my like first love yeah you
were part of a dance troupe
i was a part of a dance troupe called
the young entertainers
i was a tarkanian cheerleader for unlv
um basketball team
for their you know jerry tarkanian yep
um
he's a famous basketball coach in vegas
yeah um so
i cheered for their basketball team so i
was um at
you know dark sharks i think i was a
titanian dancer
um i was in pageants
every pageant you could possibly imagine
and um
i was in all the talent shows and i was
at san ginoa feast
i would perform as an individual and
then i'd also perform with my talent
troops so
performing and acting and all of that
was just like
a second nature for me so it just kind
of makes sense that acting and
performing would
continue so my parents were like yeah of
course you're gonna do that so you were
obviously popular in high school and and
elsewhere right
i know it's hard to say like yes because
a lot of people that are going i don't
want to sound like a but
i mean you're a cheerleader you're a
pretty girl you're you know you were
talented you were doing all these things
but
i the all that stuff i did i did it
outside of school so it's kind of like
this
music theater nerd i felt like on the
inside internally i wasn't like the cool
girl
but i think and like my
you know i think people probably knew
who i was i had an unusual name and yes
i was a cheerleader and yes i was up for
homecoming queen but like
i wasn't um i don't think i was like
everybody's favorite if that makes any
sense i mean you had a lot of friends
i mean i liked my friends i was happy
with my friend group
you're dancers and you know when was
like a
you know future dartmouth engineer
person and
the other one was like well danced well
enough to be in the american ballet
theater and
you know i had a great group
well-rounded people no i i mean i have
to ask you about this because it just
stunned me when i read it i talked to
you about it before
but the whole thing where you're
swimming in san diego with your buddies
and this whole thing happened i mean we
don't have to go into it that much but
like
it's something that just doesn't happen
to people and when it does it's so
shocking to everyone else around you
that was it just one of those things
where this guy walks up to you and your
friends at the beach what what
you know paint the picture here study
that you bring that up because
just yesterday that guy that was
released on
parole uh that beat up that elder woman
the asian woman
right you know all the asian hate that's
going around
and i was reading about it in the new
york post
it turns out that he had committed
murder he actually murdered his mother
when he was 19 years old in front of his
five-year-old sibling
goes to jail and gets out in 2018
i guess is paroled in 2018 had been
living in a homeless shelter
and um there's no refit revisit it
revis um how do you say it i don't know
you don't ask me about these words ryan
what the hell does that mean basically
it's about you know it's sort of like
helping people
not repeat the same thing that they did
oh yeah you know it helps
rehabilitate it kind of bridges the gap
between being paroled and your new life
and getting reacquainted into society so
there's no revisionism that's
embarrassing
but actually kind of funny too it's a
hard word and i've never heard of it
before
recidivism recidivism revisit recidivism
i think it's recidivism um i would look
it up but i had to hold my computer
um so anyway there was no program but
what i was feeling
is that you know
he he oh my god he
murdered somebody right he's not a
you know in jail for life and so i think
about that and i think about
like how much work we have to do in that
regard and police reform and and just
how unfortunate like all this is coming
up and i think
why this comes up for me too is that the
bystanders that were watching
what happened to that um asian woman
being accosted and assaulted on
and violently violated on the street
there were three people on the inside
that were watching it happen and they
didn't intervene in fact they closed the
door on her
and that reminds me of what happened to
me when i was on the beach
because why it triggers me is because
when what happened to me happened i was
running
like it was summer and everybody was um
parked along the freeway it you know on
the beach
and i was running going to cars knocking
on campers and going from car to
camper pounding like help me help me and
nobody came
nobody came to my rescue and so
the next day you know whenever it comes
out like the news is out
and i see it on the news and i'm like
watching
people be interviewed and they're
they've come out in groves they're
everybody's on camera talking about what
they saw and what they heard
and i was blown away because i was so
hurt because i thought you know
where were they when you were you when i
needed right
right what why they wanted to make the
news
they wanted to be on the news and they
wanted to say i was there and i it gives
them some kind of validation
maybe i don't know but it really makes
me so
so sad
inside of you is brought to you by
capsule michael isn't going to the
pharmacy
the worst uh ryan it's the absolute
worst
you ever run out of your prescription
and dread getting a refill
yeah okay in this world ryan you can get
pretty much
anything anything delivered to your door
so why are we still going to the
pharmacy to pick up our prescriptions
i i just tried this really great service
it's called capsule
okay capsule pharmacy and it's made my
life
that much easier capsule's a new kind of
pharmacy that hand delivers your
prescription the same day
for free to start visit capsule.com it
takes 15 seconds to sign up and when
your prescription's ready capsule will
text you to schedule free delivery at a
time you choose then a capsule courier
hand delivers your medication
to your door straight from the pharmacy
in a tamper-proof package
it's totally secure yeah and if you have
any questions you can call text or email
with an expert pharmacist
it's that simple no more waiting in line
no more driving to the pharmacy no more
forgetting
refills best of all even though it's a
way better experience capsule doesn't
cost
any more than your old pharmacy i should
have started with
that few people think you know what i
should switch pharmacies
because who cares right that's before
trying capsule pharmacy
one customer wrote you guys are the best
please walk me down the aisle at my
wedding one day
six thousand five star reviews everyone
loves this service because
it is so easy capsule accepts all major
insurance and is currently available in
new york city in the surrounding
tri-state area
austin boston chicago the twin cities
nla and other cities are coming very
soon
to sign up it's so easy visit
capsule.com
capsulecapsule.com to get your
prescription hand delivered
today for free that's capsule.com
inside of you is brought to you by the
lovely people
at better help better help online
therapy in
may it's may's mental health awareness
month and throughout
may throughout june
inside of you is proud to join the cause
of destigmatizing
therapy how many times have we talked
about this on the show to guests
or reading copy um it's just something
that's
so obvious that uh we're in a new world
now folks
we want to be in a healthier place we
want to be in a healthier world we want
to be around people who
can understand us and they don't judge
us if you're struggling with
relationships you're having difficulty
sleeping difficulty meeting your goals
if you're feeling anxious or stressed
better help counselors can listen and
they can help
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional you can start communicating
in under 48 hours
you know i remember growing up even
talking to my dad it comes from a
different time period where it's like i
don't need therapy i don't need that i'm
like are you
kidding me because you do i see so many
people in the past that are you know
and and now you know my dad did go to
therapy a little bit
and it did help him and um
i think it helps everybody i you know i
i'm not just speaking for myself
everybody i've talked to who decides
that they need to speak to someone else
objectively about
issues and their things that they bottle
up um
you want to come out on top you want to
come you know you want you want to get
through things
looking forward you don't want to be
looking back looking back is depression
folks that's what they say look
what is it looking back as depression
looking too far into the future is uh
anxiety look this isn't a crisis line
it's not self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online
therapists have a broad range of
expertise that may not be locally
available in your area
the service is available for clients
worldwide login to your account anytime
send a message to your counselor you can
schedule weekly video
phone or even live chat sessions i like
to see my therapist you don't have to
you could just
use a phone or you could chat with them
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available boy is that true
i'm telling you you go to another you go
to a therapist you're gonna spend
hundreds of dollars these guys are a
heck of a lot cheaper
so many people have been using
betterhelp that they're recruiting
additional counselors in all
50 states our listeners get 10 off their
first month
of online therapy at betterhelp.com
inside that's better h-e-l-p-com
inside let me ask you so
you're doing all this acting you're
doing all the i mean
once you start auditioning things what
was your first break what was the first
thing that all of a sudden you go
that you get that you get um well
my first job was baywatch and i didn't
expect to get it
but that wasn't the breakthrough the
breakthrough was when i realized
something
was happening was apparently i did
baywatch and it aired
and then a agent named wendy green
who i think was at irv schecter at the
time she represented young people
called me at my home i don't know how
she got my phone number i didn't have
any idea maybe she got it from jeff
goldblum
no but that's a good idea and
um she called and she said she wanted to
represent me
and so i think that was a turning point
you know
just off baywatch she saw you and said
this girl's got something
i guess and you just did one episode
yeah
was it fun being on a set where did you
shoot in hawaii where'd you shoot
no we didn't we shot locally and all my
scenes were with hobie the young kid
was he nice at the time no
he's nice now at the time now so what
was it he was cocky he was like i'm on
baywatch
maybe a little bit of that and i
felt he was a little too forward and i
and it was interesting because i was 24
playing
13. so i was playing 11 years younger
than myself
and i think when all of that happened it
made everybody
nervous because of the age disparity
and they needed to have an advocate on
the set and i
just kind of felt like i needed the
advocate
right not him um because he was a little
bit
forward um more than i would would have
liked at the time but
from what i understand now and i've
bumped into him since then
um he's grown as a person so well that's
good because he was like
13 or 14 at the time so imagine being on
the biggest show in the world
oh my god that age making tons of money
you know the world is your oyster
and everything that comes through you
know and he was only 13 or 14 when he's
filming this
i think so i think he was around that
age oh i had no idea wow i'm so glad
that i had no success until i was
you know mid-20s yeah because i just
even then i was so
i just was immature i just you know i i
you know i didn't grow up till i
i didn't like i didn't start puberty
till late i didn't get my first girl
till later i didn't
i wasn't popular about your first girl
when your first girlfriend
well i think the first time i had sex
was maybe when i was 18 but like
i was always like oh rosie's so cute and
he's so little and they pinch my cheeks
and
i never grew until like after high
school and then i grew to six feet tall
but i remember
going home crying i swear to god this is
true i remember crying my parents going
dad you're six five mom's five seven
what kind of drugs did you do look at me
i'm
[ __ ] short and i ran up to my room
and i remember them laughing
but like it is laughable but it's like i
thought i was never gonna grow i thought
i was never gonna grow
you do not like i've seen you in person
i thought you were taller than six feet
i'm six on the dot like 72 inches
i'm not really yeah i'm not i'm not any
taller yeah
but like i just remember just the
insecurities but like to
get success at that age like i don't
even have these people survive i mean at
least you were 24 years old at least you
were
turning into a woman at this point and
you had some experience behind you and
you had a decent upbringing
yeah and then after that she became your
agent and things took off
yeah what was what was next what was the
big thing um i think the next big thing
i think the first thing my first series
was malibu shores
malibu shores now now is it similar to
baywatch is it like a sort of like a
soap opera thing
um it was aaron spelling and it was kind
of along the lines of a
of a show called cannon dune road that
didn't end up going but it was with
carrie russell
tony um
oh my god i'm speaking of what's his
name essence atkins was on it randy
um spelling was on it um
you know it was a gr it was a great
great people
to be working with you know top of their
game kind of people
a lot of them well carrion and tony they
were on
um the disney they were disney kids the
mouseketeer kids
you know during that time when like ryan
and justin and all those people were
coming in christina
wow did you ever get star struck did you
ever on any of these shows never
was it what was the first time you got
star struck um
the first one like okay i'll tell you it
was last section hero the movie
ironically that eliza was in as a kid
um and i was a caterer to the movie
premiere
and um i was catering for the food
and then i went on a break and it went
around my table and
arnold schwarzenegger came at me came
towards me to go to
the table i guess but somebody else had
taken over and i'm faced with him face
to face i'm looking at him he's looking
at me i can't speak
he he's looking at me expecting me
probably to say something
i don't say anything and then he turns
to his people because he had like
a round of people around him and says
where's the food
and i was like i lost it now katsu
years later i'm at the expendables world
premiere
at planet hollywood in las vegas arnold
and
and sly are like best friends we're
backstage about to go into
the main stage and and arnold's there
and i end up approaching him and going i
met you that a long long time ago
you there's no way you would remember
this and he didn't
but i remember you catered the food i
was so hungry
i was so hungry and then um i said
um i did want to tell you something i
said when i was at playhouse west
one of the a part of the curriculum was
that you had to read 1500 pages a week
and do a book report at the end of every
week so that you could learn
something and also be able to um
glean from a script the essence of the
story
like that you could understand what a
story was and you knew what good writing
was
they had a they had a reading list
anyway on
you could also read any autobiography so
i read his
and i said to him you know one of the
most lasting impressions i had of
reading one of your books was
when you met um maria shriver's dad
he'd ask you what do you do and he went
to answer and he goes no what do you do
to help
people and i just thought that was such
a powerful thing
wow and i've never forgotten it
and while i was talking to him
rosie i swear to god like laser
sharp focus he makes you feel like there
is nobody else in the room he has
a thing this
it's not quantifiable you can't even i
can't even identify what it is
but it it's this ability to 110
focus listen super intently
i don't know what's going on his mind
everybody's it's super loud where we
were
and it was like super sharp focus on
everything i was saying and he was just
he commented back that like that was a
very memorable he was like really glad
that i read the book and
so flattered and yes it was awesome
thing and
you know he was very very congenial it
was
really made an impression on me so
meeting schwarzenegger you were that's
that's the one thing that
struck my name at schwarzenegger and
then you read his book and you got were
you
so excited i bet you were just like this
book when i was a kid right and then you
got you wanted to come up you're like
you had something to talk about so many
times people come up to actors or
whatever
and they're like hey
but like it's it's cool i mean i love
when people have something to say to me
i'm very cool if they don't but it's
nice if they say hey
i read this no i didn't read that
because you didn't write a book
uh you know but it's not it's definitely
nice when they have some kind of like
question or something that
to say it was nice that you got a little
star struck and he
gave you his undivided attention i like
that yeah he was great he was
he was a great he
gives he makes you feel
heard that's nice yeah i think that's
important to be heard you know
i said this before but like what he said
where
maria shriver's father said to him what
do you do know what do you do for people
like what do you do
what do you like what importance do you
bring you know it's like that saying
where
it's not what you do on camera to look
like oh look i'm so giving i'm talking
to this kid i'm helping but
what do you do when the cameras are off
you know that's that shows the real
individual and i think that's really
important and i've learned from that
i've learned to because you always when
the camera's rolling turn it on rosie
you know be the cheese ball oh look oh
we're here
but it's when the cameras are off and
you could really make a difference
you know and um those are the moments
that i
that the moments that only i know about
with certain people or certain kids or
you know driving out to some family's
house to have dinner or
and it's just me and nobody else knows
except now you
those are the moments that i'm like this
is this gives you purpose
you know what gives you purpose oh my
god that's
that's um
such a great question i
feel 2020
really helped me decide that
and um i think i want to leave a legacy
of my of i think the one legacy i would
want to leave behind for my son
would be
you know several things
i think he gives me purpose in this
sense
so it goes back to this we were in a car
once and i was driving him to soccer
practice
and he was talking about here he could
never work a job nine to five
but he's just not cut out for the nine
to five life i said
i feel you i wouldn't do that either i'm
you know that's why i love acting and
why i get to
yeah but you know you don't
write the scripts and you don't you know
you design the sets and you don't craft
the wardrobe
you know palette and you didn't you know
blah blah blah he was like completely
minimizing what i do for a living and
like something that's super important to
me
like that i love doing like i am so
passionate about what i do i love acting
i
can't bridle it i can't predict it i
don't know how it's gonna go
and it's like forever challenging me in
that sense and i love that about it but
he's attacking
me and not really holding me like
in like not even acknowledging like how
hard it is to even get a job
how old is he how old is he when he's
saying this
he was you know probably 13 14
right just a little punkish and
age and so he and i just well i
said i went to tell him you know you
should probably maybe
enroll in yada and get an idea of like
what all is involved in acting because
it's a lot more
than what you're making it sound to be
and it's a very collated collaborative
thing
and i was kind of like on the defensive
and
and just saying you know before you
start casting aspersions of what you
think it is maybe
you should have the experience before
you kind of put it down
and i said and it gave the example of
like marlon brando like
as an amazing as a screenwriter as
francis ford couple
is he did not write what marlon brando
devised
as the character of don corleone like
putting the moth ball you know
judding the june doing the boys
you know marlon came up with that so i
kind of tried to
explain to him the difference between
you know
writing something and bringing it to
life to make my point
so anyway that has been a huge
driving force in me so in 2020
i found purpose in
you know finding my own path creating my
own projects so based out of my
childhood
experience as a young entertainer i
wrote a co-wrote a script called the
young entertainers
or the untitled charisma carpenter
project and i also created another
project called karen gets cancelled
which i have
i'm i made a deck with my co-creator dan
merchant who's worked on like z nation
and all these great shows and
um we're pitching that we're looking for
actually looking for a black part a
production company to partner with
i'm very passionate about incorporating
you know everything that we're trying to
do in society today more inclusivity
whether it's lgbtq people
or black talent in front and behind the
camera
definitely bringing more diversity into
the writers rooms
you know this is like i want to be about
it you know i really want to be about it
so that gives me purpose and i created
my con as you know
in 2020 which is just sort of like a fan
talent connection i love talking to
people
i did it i love doing it i love talking
to you on it you're really good at it
you're just good at it well and so
like i love the idea of creating
something in a
platform for you know carefully
i want to curate the group of people all
sci-fi based
i'm not interested in being cameo i
don't want to have
youtubers like bagel boss on there where
they're like making money on misogyny
and creating
you know platform where they giving them
an avenue to make money on their
misogyny
that doesn't align with me so that's why
my con is so important to me and then
also it's an opportunity for me to give
back to the two charities i care about
which is in africa um
and um well there's project shine which
i care about there's actually threes
i i don't um give i give privately to
project shine
but my con is set up where um a
percentage of
all my sales total sales i send to the
ronan thompson foundation which is
you know cancer for kids pediatric
cancer
research and the other one is called the
thirst product which is how i came to go
to africa at all and that's
bringing water around the world so those
are the things that like give me purpose
inside of you is brought to you by nitsa
i'm not going very far i'm in a rush
it's too uncomfortable well sometimes i
just forget
don't kid yourself folks there's no such
thing as a good excuse for not
buckling up come on if you've ever used
any of these excuses or any others
you're putting yourself at risk or
of injury or death you're also putting
other people
at risk in 2019 nearly 10 000 people
were unbuckled when they were killed in
crashes
that's 43 percent of people killed in
motor vehicle crashes that were not
wearing seat belts no matter what kind
of vehicle you drive wearing your
seatbelt is the best defense
in a crash even when you sit in the back
seat you still need to buckle up
that goes for when you ride in taxis use
ride sharing services too
law enforcement are on the lookout and
writing tickets so why
why why take the risk seat belts save
lives
so do the smart thing and buckle up
every trip day
or night click it or ticket
paid for by nitsa inside of you is
brought to you by
geico geico geico
uh michael you own your home i i do own
my home
it's uh it's you know it's it's always
the tough thing to do
to pay your mortgage and you rent your
home
yeah yes we talked about that yeah you
got to pay the rent every uh
every month yeah and you got other
things to pay we've got auto we've got
insurance yeah
all the calls imagine imagine if you
could just pay
one place you don't say i do
do you geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowners or renters insurance
along
with your auto policy ryan oh my god
it's a good thing because
you already have so much to do around
your house or your apartment
just go to geico.com get a quote
okay co easy visit geico.com
that's geico.com inside of you is
brought to you by
10 000 i don't know about you but when i
work out and working out is such a pain
in the butt
anyway right so most people it's hard
enough to get them to work out so when
you do work
out you you want to be comfortable 10
000 makes the highest quality
best fitting and most comfortable
training shorts
i have ever owned the seven inch
interval short with the liner and the
lightweight shirt
is just incredible and i'll tell you i
don't like working out and when i do
i have to be comfortable i don't want
chafing folks you don't want chafing
you got to try these guys out ten
thousand at the core of ten thousand or
three core training shorts
built for all the ways we train the
interval short
versatile and great for hiit spinning
metcons short runs and anything else you
can think of
the foundation short built for
durability for tough gym days and
outdoor adventures
the session short super lightweight
perfect for running yoga
and mobility 10 000 is a direct to
consumer company no middleman
you get premium fabrics trims techniques
that other brands
simply cannot afford pick the short that
is best for your training and then
personalize it with custom liner and
inseam options
over 9 500 5 star reviews
free shipping and returns and a lifetime
guarantee
and guess what ryan what 10 000 is
offering our listeners
fifteen percent off their purchase by
just going to ten thousand
dot cc and enter the code
inside that's ten thousand
inside you're going to want to try this
product
and you know what the only thing i could
think of was when your 13 year old young
man
said that to you i would have been like
this is the difference between you and i
i would have been like
what are you doing what have you done
what have you done it with your life at
which is a comedy right there it's like
in his responsibility i'm 13 mom
not sure he would have actually said
that that's what you said i'm not
supposed to do anything at 13.
yeah i'm not i'm not supposed to be
doing anything at 13 that's true
um but certain people are 13 are that
way i wasn't that person at 13. were you
did you know that you were gonna
be do what you do make a living and then
turn that into a podcast
i never thought i'd be i don't want to
make it sound dramatic but to say like i
had a death wish but like i when i was a
kid i never thought i'd survive past
high school i thought
i just i'm not gonna make it through it
and then i was like i'm not gonna make
it in the real world i just don't i just
can't fit in i can't i'm not smart
enough
the way i thought was so toxic
and and i just believe that i didn't
belong and it wasn't until you know i
found
acting really i just fell into it where
i felt like i had something like
somebody thought i was good at something
and they gave me that attention that i
just craved and you know needed as a
child
and so you know i think acting for me i
mean but i did not have a clue to what i
was going to do i mean i honestly
thought when i graduated high school
i'll pump gas
my mom knew the guy at the gas station
at shell and i would work at wesleyan's
grocery sacking bags maybe
that's it so i thought my my self
narrative was um and by the way isn't
that
a pleasant surprise how your life turned
out like i love the stories that you
were telling on my con when you were
talking about
um living with carrie fisher at her
house
and all the people that came through
yeah you have a lot of fancy friends
well i'm a fancy friend person i really
don't have fancy friends but i you know
as much as i
i have these a lot of celebrity friends
and i know a lot of people i don't hang
out with them
a lot my friends are very just
not industry with um
kristen bell and her husband well dax is
a close friend of mine for a long time
but he was nobody when i met him when we
were just we we became good friends but
uh and then kristen i ended up doing a
movie with her and dax but i i wasn't
i've never been close with kristen but
enough like if she saw me she'd give me
a big hug and
you know but we're not like you know
there's a there's a loose term
in hollywood and that word is friends
it's
it's very easy to say oh yeah i'm
friends with someone some friends or
something no i'm acquaintances with a
lot of people and i like a lot of people
doing this podcast i'm able to actually
get to know
them more and know so have some insight
and i think we become better friends or
maybe it's more appropriate after i talk
to them
with this you know long conversation
that maybe
it's possible that you could be friends
with them or maybe you are better
friends because you know something about
them
but i can't say that i'm friends with
people that i don't know if i just see
somebody go
i don't even know your last name or i
don't know where you work i don't know
where you grew up i don't know
these are things that i you know and
like ryan ryan's a friend of mine and
um you know i hang out with a group of
people that are mostly non-actors i i
think i don't feel
i hang out with a lot of people i just
don't ever feel that i mean i do have
actor friends i'll go to a laker game
i'll do these things
but i never felt like i fit in that's
still to this day i i could pretend
you wouldn't know yeah but it's really
interesting you say that because
everything that i like my my impressions
when i first met you
uh and really spent the most amount of
time with you i think we were in
philly we might have been in philly at a
convention yeah yeah
and we were in the band together and
chatting and you're like you got to come
on my podcast i was like i'd love to
come on your podcast and then like
it's taken us three years to make it
happen but
but i remembered really
at that point hitting it
turning the corner because my impression
was that you were a bit of a womanizer
sure if you knew me when i was early 20s
then
probably no no this is just like
i didn't know you i didn't actually ever
even see you in person
this is just sort of i don't even know
it's rumors rumors see we gotta be
careful about rumors because i hear
things
i don't think i was like necessarily
[Music]
in a position to be talking about you so
i don't know if it was
i just i don't know where it came from i
don't remember ever having a
conversation about
you and somebody's saying anything
disparaging about you because i don't
think that ever happened
oh i'm sure i just probably just got
this vibe that you know you're
you're kind of into you know
you know womanizing and um
you know not to be taken too seriously
you don't take women seriously you're
probably not a good listener
and it's like all those preconceived
ideas
are out the window because when i start
to talk to you i realize like
you know you're you're an easy you're
easy to laugh with you're easy to talk
to
um you're really sweet um you care about
people
you actually have a pockets where you
are forced to listen to people
clearly yes you know um
you know just it's just been such a
great
eye-opening experience for me because i
really probably would never i
if you ever had impression me it was
probably like ice queen
like because i just just
you just my idea of who i thought you
were
was just you were not somebody i really
wanted to get to know see i think that
goes with a lot of people like there's
people on tv shows that i go oh i hear
that guy's an [ __ ] he's a douchebag
but i'm like who am i to judge i haven't
met this person i don't know this person
and we all do it
we all do it i could see you on the
plane you would be very fussy
you know about like you know um
you're i don't know if there's like a
window or a seat you're physically i'm
i'm claustrophobic i'm claustrophobic i
can't sit in the window
and you were like talking to the
stewardess and needing things
and like on the phone at the same time
with a girl facetiming on the plane
which i thought was so rude
and i was just like i just was watching
you and just going your linus
all i see is just like a lot of dust
and just like noise you know wow like
that
i just had these horrible well
you can't judge a book by his cover and
by the way by the way no
this is totally true i was completely
just determined to just have the you
know and that says a lot for
you know my judgments and who i am you
know like how much growing i need to do
and have done
you know to just be open to to see and
experience you in a different way
yeah and i'm so pleasantly surprised
well like it's funny you say that
because i you know i look i always
thought you were
like i was like i don't know she doesn't
like people she's she's kind of distant
she's cold
she's i don't know she seems like she
might be difficult these are all things
that
i thought of and then i started talking
and i'm like
wow she's uh she's cool
because i didn't know you but i you know
we don't know each other
exactly we all like to think especially
young look look to say just sit here and
say that i you know
i'm perfect i'm beyond imperfect
but and i own up to it but like you know
in my 20s
talk about a lost soul i was like a
little puppy dog looking for love
in all their own places looking to get
attention look to looking at some kind
of fulfillment in my life
and thank god you know my 30s rolled
around and i started to meet more mature
women who
i ended up having long relationships and
becoming great friends with and
growing as a human being and that's a
decision you make you
you make that decision to either
continue going on in a way that you just
seem lost
or you go i am going to explore who i
really am and no matter how dark and how
difficult people like to go there i
don't know
i don't know nobody can do that work
believe me i don't
not nobody obviously you do and i really
have
but um well you're sweet for saying nice
things
no you i said a lot of things that i
that weren't so nice
well i mean but those were not about
where my head was it was very
judgey exactly but it's something of you
that's
okay okay that's okay look i'm sure a
lot of look here's the reality if you're
a guy
or a girl and you break up with someone
or you don't want to see them anymore or
whatever you're an [ __ ]
you're a douchebag you're a womanizer
and if you're a girl
and you don't and you don't call the guy
back you don't give another chance
you're a [ __ ]
and it's just like this cyclical thing
that goes on and on into time about how
bad everybody is
but how about 99 of the time you don't
end up with the right person 99
of the time and the one percent time you
do you end up getting a divorce that's
that's a harsh reality in the world so
you know you're going to make mistakes
you can't be the best guy
to everybody but you could do you do the
best you can and you hopefully learn
from it am i wrong
you're not wrong i mean i think twice
i didn't get it right so you were
divorced twice
no you weren't really well
did you how much did you learn from that
and how horrible is it to go through a
divorce
or is it the second one easier the
second one was like
so easy it was a minimum it was six it
was six months he didn't want anything i
didn't want anything
and it was just like dissolve wow no
no drama nothing it was super simple why
can't all divorces be like that i hear
the worst things in the world the first
divorce was hard
it was heartbreaking and how do you get
through it
um
i mean i had a son i
you know friends their family i have an
amazing family
my family is so so supportive they're
in fact it was so bad my stepmother
and my dad have
uh have a son you know my stepbrother
his name is rob
he robs gay and rob had a partner at the
time his name was marshall
and my parents parents had a family
meeting
there over there in indiana and
marshall said he was gonna my parents
said that they wanted to fly marshall to
come and stay with me to help me
like you know
go through the divorce not him help me
with the divorce part but just like help
me manage
like i was having trouble eating i
couldn't sleep
i you know i was
devastated yeah but that's a good family
the logistics of it all and
you know meet with lawyers and you know
um paperwork and
like looking at all the things that i
had i had to put on my business hat
and kind of put my heart aside and
and just look at it like that
and then deal with the emotional fallout
after
and that was kind of like hard to do
to manage it all well and i just
remember one day when i went to pick up
my son from
kindergarten he had the sweetest
teacher and i went in to see her
and she looked at me and she
i don't know why she just gave me this
big hug
and it was like i don't know if you can
imagine like the she was like um
a heavier set woman and she had an
accent
and she was always so sweet and she just
gave me this hug and i
she must have been intuitively knew to
hug me
and i just broke like it just because i
was
staying strong for my son i didn't want
to cry in front of him i didn't want to
like and i
and it was you know my husband at the
time was the love of my life
at that point and i just couldn't
believe this was happening and i
couldn't ever i didn't really have time
to deal with it emotionally and when she
hugged me
i just it was so unexpected because i'm
not a hugger
um unless it's on my terms like unless
we have like a really close friendship
like i just didn't i
it wouldn't normally be something that i
would want right
or necessarily want to receive but
you needed in that time in that moment
you needed that and she knew it
and yeah just held me and i just
well you know what i think that that's
the weirdest thing i i try to play
like i don't have emotions sometimes so
i'm not going to let this get to me
and it's the little it's the little
things
that just can trigger an emotion
yeah and the the friend that you didn't
think you'd break down in front of
the least likely character or the that
moment that you just
didn't expect and it's just the right
time
it's it's on your watch it's like your
emotional watch it's almost like
it goes it ticks it has it's you know it
ticks by itself it's like
it it's gonna the alarm's gonna go off
when it goes off and it's not telling
you and something
something so sweet or subtle can just
open up the floodgates and that that's
happened to me many a time where i
i have to leave the room because i can
get so emotional i mean i've gotten
i've gotten so emotional just from a kid
from the ronald mcdonald house i
remember
um i was fine i acted fine and then i
started telling the story
to one of my friends and i was just like
yeah he's just so sweet and then he's
just
gonna out the shirt like
oh my god oh my god okay and i was just
a mess like i was like it just hit me i
was like why am i crying in front of you
i'm telling a story
i got so mad at myself i'm like oh my
god i'm so sorry
i can't believe i'm doing this and like
no no it's totally cool and they were
like
oh my god rose mum's you know but they
were cool and uh
but anyway thank you for sharing that
that's you know there's
there's definitely been a couple of
times where i've had loss
and you know i know that i know from
talking to friends who've had divorces
it is a loss it is like it's like losing
somebody it's like a death
am i right um it really
i really feel like yeah i think yeah
okay
yes i feel like that was very very hard
it was very hard all right this is the
fun time of the
the trip i mean we can talk about a
couple of things but this is [ __ ]
talking with charisma carpenter this is
um
rapid fire um except this first question
lauren w no question just want to high
five you charisma for standing up for
everyone that had to endure
a toxic work environment those of us too
scared to do so
applaud you let's see
i mean i'm sure you were like going i
hope he doesn't talk about this but you
knew i was going to talk about little
it's pretty much out there
but you know i keep thinking it's like
you know this was the same time i was
doing probably smallville and you're
doing buffy and angel
and all this stuff and i don't know what
it's like to be a woman i'll never know
what it's like to be a woman and it's
[ __ ] hard i could tell how hard it is
and you how people
look at you and what was it the the
thing that kind of the straw that broke
the camel's back that felt you felt like
this is toxic like that i mean there's
probably little things along the way but
what what is it that
is it you know because i'm not really i
don't know a lot about this
other than it was a toxic work
environment and a lot of people
supported you and said yes it was and i
was like oh wow and i don't really know
the inside scoop
other than um i know some issues when
you were pregnant and things like that
um and it just sounded awful but i just
wanted to hear it from you
yeah um i'm too keen talking about it
because
i think i think honestly
i was really descriptive with my letter
for that reason you know and so like
when it all kind of happened
i was getting a lot of invitations from
you know like the today show or the view
or like
all these people gail king you know
calling to
have a conversation about it and i
really wanted to be clear
that um this wasn't about publicity
this isn't about a publicity tour to
kind of like
you know share my air my gree you know
like
laundry or whatever in the sense that
it's a that it's
because people and the world at large
based on my own social media
um are cynical of that kind of stuff
you know they think that that's why
you're saying it you know they think
that that's
what's happening and i think um
you know it's disappointing to hear that
that
the that's where the head goes
um but i'm sure in some cases that has
happened
so it's fair but um
i just really feel like i said
everything that i needed to say and it
took me
two weeks to write that letter and every
word choice
you know i had a typo in there which
still begs me but
like what was the typo do you worry
about a typo people don't worry about
you don't know but like
it literally like i worked so hard
editing it crafting it
saying this not saying that what do i
want to say
what you know what instances should i
choose to say
like i really said
everything i could have possibly wanted
to say on the subject
there and it was very articulate i mean
it really spoke volumes
and did it feel like it was like an
elephant
out of the room like or you know the
monkey off your back like you felt like
once you did it it felt really just good
to get it out there because it's
something that had been bottling up for
so many years
um actually it was really stressful it
was really stressful
the two weeks knowing that it was coming
that i was crafting it
then when i had to push post that was
really stressful i thought literally i
was gonna lose my bowels in my bed
um i'm sure i'm sure
that in a whole other way um like
quite literally i had gurglies and
you know and i think that's kind of like
two why i had to do it because i knew
how it made me feel and i knew i was
taking a really big
really big risk by saying this because
you know i go to cons all the time
and you know it's a great deal of my
income
and these days and i was really
putting myself in a position to alienate
my fandom
and speaking out against the creator of
my show
where i go to these conventions and
people walk with t-shirts on their backs
saying like joss whedon is my god so
i was really afraid of
insulting them offending them alienating
them
and i really had no idea that co-workers
were gonna like i
really never imagined sarah saying
anything
or like i was really
really just as shocked as everybody like
you just
yeah everybody just your work when your
co-workers were saying [ __ ] then you're
like wow
i i did not see that i i thought maybe
deadline
would pick it up i had no idea
you had no expectations you just thought
i want to do this because i want to do
this
and no i wanted to do for ray i think
it's easier
to advocate for other people than
for yourself and i knew certainly 20
years ago that wasn't an option
so well i i appreciate it 20 years later
that the same person was doing the same
things
you know i i had grown um
i had met ray at a con we became very
good friends through a con
and you know that's how how it all how
our conversation
kind of started and how our
how then like three months later he last
summer
he said what he said and then he like
once in my name on on social media and
then i was like really under pressure
and i wanted to do something behind the
scenes you know
in my own time yeah and when he
was let go from the cyborg role
cyborg role i
i was that was that i didn't do it
well i appreciate yeah and we don't have
to talk about it but it was a good way
of talking around it about look you said
everything you said in the in the tweet
if you guys want to read or tweet it's
pretty
freaking powerful and a lot of other
actors from the show stepped up
and supported her and i think that's
pretty fantastic
on its own uh this is quick really quick
raj who are some people you felt tried
to make the work environment on set a
positive experience who were some but
people that you just loved working with
i mean
most people i enjoyed working with there
wasn't like
you know um my who i had the most fun
with
was nikki because we had a lot of scenes
together as lovers
and he is naturally very funny
and he has a great sense of humor and so
you know i had a lot of fun working with
him in the early years
little lisa did you take any props or
wardrobe from buffy or angel
how many did you really i take
so many you're like me that's what i do
i'm the only one that takes props from
my set
oh no i have my chair you have the chair
that you were telling me
i have my hair i have my trophy i have
my burnt certain um
high school diploma i have a lot of
clothes i got rid of a lot of clothes
but i still have my
benetton lime green trench coat that i
wore
um i have my teddy bear from bad eggs
um i have just like me you're just like
me
i have every single script with every
single note i ever made
um in every script saved in these ink
preserving boxes um
i save and keep everything i'm not quite
sole moon fry did you see her
documentary
very powerful 90s kid all right i'm
going to i was told to watch it i'm
going to watch it very
very powerful all right she knew a lot
of people she had a lot of fancy friends
too like
oh stop it um she she
filmed everything so like i didn't
film anything but i kept a lot of
and took a lot of pictures i like that i
like that because we're kind of like
kids in a candy store this is
it's an exciting thing to do when you're
on a set it's like you know i always
feel that and i want to
i want to take something home i want to
take a picture i'm going to remember it
and like other actors like no i don't
have pictures i don't have autographs i
don't have
you look around my house like a museum
like in certain rooms that's just who i
am
i think that's amazing i mean i don't
have it on display but
maybe someday i will look this has been
a blast i i i've learned so much
freaking about you now that i didn't i
just didn't know
you know it's like with you like you
were talking
about all this stuff and places you've
been and people you knew
and experiences you had and your
insecurities
and we could go on
i thought that you thought that you were
this good you know and you were out
there just like
getting the girls and yeah i mean it was
so sweet to see like how you're like
just like me please well look it's not
like i
look i i went out with girls i went look
you're young you're in hollywood you're
gonna go out with a lot of girls unless
you're an idiot
you're good i mean look not an idiot but
like i'm a lost young guy from indiana
who is the only one to get out and do
something was
so immature and i was just like oh my
god it's a kid in a candy store they're
giving me free stuff
and there's girls and there's did you
ever sleep with anybody you worked with
on
small business never never never never
never never there was a very
there's a lot of respect on that set
there was always
i mean did we there was some flirts sure
people flirted there's pretty girls
there's cute guys most of the guys i
think i flirted with more
you know it was just it was that you
know that you don't [ __ ] where you eat i
think
no no no no i i have lots of gay friends
but i'm not gay
um i made out with uh jason isaacs in
sweet november
it wasn't scripted but we made it out in
the back in the scene and the director's
like mike that's very nice but we don't
need that
you don't have to kiss or anything
because we're not really seeing you on
camera so
you're wasting the french kiss off
camera anyway we
but jason isaacs and i did we kissed and
i have no issues with that i'm very
comfortable with my sexuality um
a lot of gay friends uh you know i yeah
i don't i don't care about that stuff
but uh no i've never been with a man um
that's not my favorite
lady uh i think i have been
a lady you say a lady
well let me see um i could talk to you
forever
so another time but thank you so much
for being flexible with me today
honestly yes this has been awesome and
you look fantastic you were saying
honestly
when you text me and you were like you
were saying you were 50 which you could
look up it's not like it's
i honestly ryan on my mother's life may
i drop
dead you could pass for like early 30s
no
what i'm looking at right now i'm
telling you early 30s i'm like
50 is have you seen 50 year old women
i mean sure i just don't think you'll
i'm
this isn't me hitting you on you this is
a friend and she's
she's 50 she's hot i'm just saying
you don't look freaking 50 anybody i
could argue with anybody on that
yes thank you thank you i appreciate
that that's kind of you
i think you look great for you know 42
49 in july yeah i'm getting there
i'm getting there oh yeah right
you can learn well it must have been all
the alcohol in your twenties
yeah jeez louise all right look i i love
you i wish you the best and
uh thank you for doing this you're very
kind and you're very brave and i
appreciate
you thank you friend
lovely episode very nice very nice uh
talking to charisma and it's been a long
time coming i've been wanting
her to get on the show for quite some
time we used to
i mean she was on the wb for a long time
i was in the wv for a long time and uh
we never really hung out a lot we just
kind of knew of each other like
we talked about yeah like yeah i heard
you were kind of like you know let me
let me tell you it's not defending
myself but you know
when you're in your 20s and you're in
hollywood there's nothing wrong with
going to parties and having a good time
and meeting the ladies especially when
you're
when you're me growing up who didn't go
out with girls
really and was the smallest kid in my
high school i definitely
had fun um but
you know i was younger and you know
that's that's the way it goes i think i
think i don't think there's anything
wrong with it but it's amazing how
people think certain things about people
because they
hear oh he's a player or he you know
you know i always consider a player
someone who tries does whatever he can
to you know
get the girl get laid yeah i never was
like that i was always just very honest
i'm not the kind of guy that's going to
go i love you i really think we got
something here
i'm not like that i've never been like
that and i don't lead people on like
that
you didn't read that book what was it
called or there was that book on paper
13 and being a dick
what is it uh was that that book on how
to
pick up women i never read a book i'm
picking up i think it was called
something like the game or something
yeah it was like something that a lot of
guys tried to do
i never i think it was just uh you know
the reason i'm single all these years is
because or i've been
in relationships three years here two
years here but you know you look at my
dysfunctional family and my
sister who's divorced four times my
mom's in her third marriage not to say
it's not a happy marriage now my dad
just when i look around i just i grew up
i didn't feel a sense of safety
and so marriage isn't a word that i
associate safety with or like comfort
so until i meet someone that i just feel
comfortable
and who knows maybe i will get married i
mean i think
who knows nobody knows who's to say uh
thank you for listening guys i
appreciate you
and please subscribe as i told you in
the beginning of the show
uh subscribe on youtube subscribe on
spotify apple stitcher etc etc
if you want to listen to the band on may
29th we've got two shows go to
sunspin.com
also got merch you can get zooms uh if
you liked the podcast and wanted a great
swag go to the inside of you online
store
and uh if you want to join patreon go to
patreon.com
inside that's p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com
slash inside of you
uh the handles are at inside of you pod
on pod on twitter at insideypodcast on
instagram
and facebook and uh also follow
the band sunspin at sunspinband on
socials
another good week ryan every week that
we're here is a good week
we're live spring is springing
spring and spring spring is springing i
like it days are looking nice
yeah i've been taking blanche with the
dog park a lot that's good she really
loves that it's
so fun to see her so happy and you know
i could feel like in the beginning for
the first couple weeks with her of
losing her
her buddy her brother you know we were
both kind of upset and i could just tell
that she was just a little bit off but
like i just
tried to keep her busy try to keep her
busy give her lots of love and know that
you know
because when she when i leave now
there's not it's not her nerves together
it's just her
and so she's like you know i didn't want
her to feel so i tried not to leave her
my friends were like hey let's go out of
town i go
it's limited limited for the first month
or two before i
am able to do that i think uh let's go
right at it uh keep listening
i love you here are the big patrons the
top tier patrons who uh
give so much the podcast all my patrons
do but uh these people give a little bit
more
and i will give them their shout outs
because i love them and they deserve it
nancy d
mary b leah asked trisha f sarah v
little lisa
yukiko jill e bryant h lauren g
nico p robin asked jerry w robert b
jason w
apathy and kristin kristen k not to be
confused with kristen crook
amelia oh allison
hell yes man you baffle me i know you
look at these but
i don't i can't do all these last names
lucas amraj c
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m jennifer
and jackie p
stacy l carly h carly s jenn asks jamal
f janelle b
carey b tab of the 272 not to be
confused with tabitha 273
ashley ryan kimberly e mike e marissa
nanier hello ed
sullivan el don sopremo dan 99 more
premier santiago m sarah f chad w
liam p ray a maya p mattie s kendrick f
ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda n kevin v james r chris h
dave h samantha s
spider-man chase sheila g ray
h tabitha t tom and
suzanne b oh my gosh
kdf liliana a michelle k marcus
w marcus thank you you know sometimes
people say hey man
you know i can't support you this month
or whatever and i'm just baffled that
they even have to write that it's just
nice
i love you guys no matter what if he's
just listening to the podcast that's
enough
if you if you can't afford to be on
patreon
i i love you just as much and i it
really means a lot to me so marcus thank
you and thank you to everybody who
continue to support me who can't support
me anymore
whatever it is you're still loved hannah
b michael s
talia m lucas h andrew t and this is the
last list right here we got betsy d
claire m liz j
laura l chat l rochelle nathan e
brandale
randall taylor k neil a
there's a cuckoo clock did you hear that
neil that's for you marion meg k
janelle p trev l it's actually travel
travel travel dan and jennifer j
wayne m diane r o jetta lorraine g olga
c
corey m carrie h veronica k big stevie w
kendall t lindsay m carroll t carol d
kdg sandy b angel m eric c rhiannon c
stephen m
corey k super sam emily k sherry s
coleman g michelle a riley j and liz
l you guys are all rock stars i
appreciate the hell out of you thanks
for listening today
please listen tomorrow and every other
day
i really appreciate it and um i wish you
nothing but health and happiness
and be good to one another be good to
yourself most importantly
uh get therapy if you need it um like i
said
you know i do so that's that from uh
michael rosenbaum here and ryan taylor's
over here in the hills of hollywood
california
california ryan look at the camera up
there give a little wave
we love you thank you each and every one
of you for allowing me to be inside of
you
all these times and continue listening
to the show and uh
make me happy all right i'll see you
around
[Music]